now we saw this coming about two weeks
ago when Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh I remember when he first
appeared before the Senate Judiciary
Committee rather than mount any serious
argument Democrats and their activist
allies resorted to theatrics and paid
pre-planned protests I welcome everyone
to this confirmation hearing on the
nomination of mr. Brett Kavanaugh mr.
chairman we cannot possibly move forward
mr. chairman during confidential
documents Chairman I appeal to be
recognized and Barnum & Bailey would
have been proud well unable to stop
Cavanaugh based on his judicial record
which is stellar
Democrats resorted to this late in the
game smear job that they tried with my
old boss Clarence Thomas 17 years ago
well you all know by now that dianne
feinstein sat on dr. christine ford's
allegation for six weeks never bringing
it to the attention of the Judiciary
Committee until of course it was
conveniently leaked well this alleged
salt assault has not been confirmed by
any of the four other people that she
claimed or at the party in question she
was 15 and Cavanaugh was 17 and then
yesterday a week after the Ford
allegation came to light another
decades-old claim surfaced this time in
the new yorker college classmate of
Kavanagh deborah ramirez claims that
while a freshman at yale he exposed
himself to her at a boozy dorm party
even though she was drinking herself at
the time of the alleged incident so much
so that she was slurring her words and
foggy ramirez says she saw Cavanaugh
pulling up his pants after someone
exposed himself to her so must have been
him must have been he note that New
Yorker writer Ronan Farrow and co-writer
Jane Mayer couched the allegation this
way in the title saying Senate Democrats
investigate new allegation of sexual
misconduct sought conduct from Brett
when I was college years so whatever the
Democrats are investigating it lacks a
witness but New Yorker admits that no
one witnessed this alleged incident in
fact mr. Ramirez's roommate miss Ramirez
his roommate who claims that they shared
everything heard nothing of it the only
person that the dynamic journalistic duo
of Pharaoh and Mayer could find to
substantiate the claim really didn't
Jane the corroborating witness which you
says has all the details including
Cavanaugh's name where did that witness
come from and where did that witness get
the information about this from if that
person doesn't know Ramirez he remembers
it from from he was in the same dorm
same same little building on Yale's old
campus and he remembers it clearly I
asked him you know very careful no I
such said he heard it from someone who
was there he heard it from someone is
someone in a small little dorm in the
old campus ooh great reporting enter
stage left the old gray lady the New
York Times reports that they spent a
week trying to verify the Ramirez story
interviewing several dozen people but
drumroll please
quote could find no one with first-hand
knowledge that's why they didn't run
with it miss Ramirez herself contacted
former Yale classmates and she asked if
they recalled if the incident ever
happened and told some of them that she
herself could not be certain that mr.
Cavanaugh was the one who exposed
himself but within the span of six days
and after consulting with classmates and
Democrats Ramirez magically recovered
her hidden memories
here's Ronan Farrow why did she come
forward
she came forward because Senate
Democrats began looking at this claim
aha
now we know why Feinstein Schumer
Gillibrand and the whole crew were so
desperately wanting to put off the
Cavanaugh Ford hearing which the
Republicans remember had originally
scheduled for today they needed their
pals in the media to have additional
time to jump on what they were
investigating the Democrats and find
someone anyone who knew Cavanaugh and
could level a salacious outrageous
charge against him oh who is Debra Merck
Ramirez we don't know all that much
about her she's a registered Democrat
who the New Yorker says works on behalf
of quote social justice and social
change close quote of course right on
cue Feinstein is now demanding that
Thursday's hearing be postponed to the
third week of never Kavanagh is himself
defiant standing his ground as he told
martha maccallum tonight the truth is
I've never sexually assaulted anyone in
high school or otherwise I am NOT
questioning and have not questioned that
perhaps dr. Ford at some point in her
life was sexually assaulted by someone
in some place but what I know is I've
never sexually assaulted anyone I want a
fair process where I can defend my
integrity and I know I'm telling the
truth
I know my lifelong record and I'm not
gonna let false accusations
drive me out of this process I have
faith in God and I have faith in the
fairness of the American people the
American people may be fair but the
Democrat jackals on the committee are
circling doesn't Kevin all have the same
presumption of innocence as anyone else
in America
I put his denial in the context of
everything that I know about him in
terms of how he approaches his cases as
I said his credibility is already very
questionable in my mind and in the minds
of a lot of my fellow judiciary
committee members
the Democrats she gave it all the way
there it's not about whether these women
have been wrong many of them probably
have it's not about respecting the
presumption of innocence either this is
about denying Donald Trump a fifth vote
on the Supreme Court but the Democrats
I'm telling you they should take a
breath and they should recognize the new
standard that they're setting here for
all nominees going forward I'm really
suggesting that all aspects that aspects
of future Democratic nominees their high
school and college behavior that should
be subjected to scrutiny and
investigation well that should be loads
of fun the Republicans should have held
the vote last week as planned ken starr
said that a week ago on this program
they should not have indulged this
circus had they done so the right way
justice Cavanaugh would already be
settling into his new chambers at the
Supreme Court and a warning if he's not
confirmed Republican voters may turn on
their party as a result and that's the
angle